i just i don't think men would be
subjected to the same kind of [ __ ]
you and i are subjected to
megan mccain is speaking out about how
she feels
society treats women it's really hurts
my feelings
it genuinely hurts my feelings the 35
year old view co-host hit up instagram
monday
to share this screenshot of an article
written about her
the title the view sets return date fans
excited for comeback
but not for megan mccain ouch
well megan wasn't having it calling the
piece garbage in the caption
saying it is an example why our culture
is so deeply toxic for women
quote no man would ever have this kind
of a headline written who co-hosts the
number one talk show in america
that just won an emmy for best show do
better
be better lift women up instead of
tearing strong ones down
i think for women in this country it's
important to know that you don't just
have to talk about
light things all the time you can do it
all but guys
keep listening because megan wasn't done
the tv personality continued
writing that women are punished for
being tough opinionated and not backing
down
while men are celebrated for it i try
and just remind myself that i'm
representing
50 of the country i'm representing a
bunch of women even though i only have
one chair
she also explained why she thinks this
country has never had a woman president
quote we raise women to be strong
independent smart
empowered and to speak their mind and
then turn around
and viciously punish them once they do
and then
subsequently proceed to demand they be
more likable warm softer smile more be
non-threatening blah blah blah
well [ __ ] that damn you tell him meg
i'm not trying to placate to an audience
instead megan said that we should
celebrate women with different opinions
i think that's important
adding that she's just not the kind of
woman who sits back
and plays it safe i think we represent
the two
polar opposites in the country and that
it's healthy there's no other place on
all of television you see women like us
debating issues and i think that's
really important megan encouraged all
women regardless of political
persuasions
to speak up and use their voice more not
less
and she wrapped it all up saying she's
sick and tired of our country not being
where she thought we'd be in the year
2020
before apologizing for what she called
her soapbox rant
that's how i feel